a bonus point to those of you who know
what a logical clock is right so I'm
gonna talk about the the coolest a tool
or platform of 2019 the features store
I'm gonna talk a bit about why it's very
Python centric and how it enables data
engineers and data scientists to
interact a bit a little bit about us
first I'm based in Stockholm and we're a
vendor of an open-source platform called
hops works it's a data platform for AI
and I thought I'd say something a little
bit topical because Sweden as many of
you know is a very gender neutral
country and I taught you show you how we
solve the problem in Sweden so I've been
living in Sweden for 15 years I teach in
Swedish so I feel kind of Swedish we've
changed the pronouns we didn't like he
and her and now in the schools we get he
in Swedish is Han and Hearns reaches
home so we actually use a gender-neutral
pronoun called him or in English hen so
if you're going to a hen party in Sweden
it could be anything it's a box of
chocolates just remember that and
remember 20 years this is what it was
okay so what I'm going to start is by
motivating the features store so you're
interested becoming a data scientist you
think it's great I love working with
Python
you know I might earn a big salary and I
might even get a chance to change the
world you could started as a very
motivated individual you've got your
tool case you've got to four notebooks
you've got Python pi torch pandas numpy
you might even have spark and tensorflow
and then you get into the real world of
the enterprise the large companies and
you come into this big sea of systems
down below data systems and you know
this might not be your cup of tea you
know you say well you know you employed
me as a data scientist but they're
paying you big books you should know all
this you should know how to use at
Google bigquery and Amazon s3 and HDFS
and so on so really one of the problems
that data scientists have and we
experience this a lot when we come to
banks and
and large companies is that data
scientists have difficulties finding
their data they've difficulty even when
they find the date of getting that data
into a format that they can use to train
models and we often have the cliche that
80% of the work is actually you know
doing the data prep and getting it out
there so as you may guess the the
feature store is motivated by this we
want to reduce the time that data
scientists spend doing looking for data
munging data feature engineering and
maximize the amount of time they do
doing proper data science and that's
where the feature store comes in so what
it is in fact is a new layer of
abstraction and it's a layer of
abstraction that separates your back-end
data systems and you have data engineers
at the backend systems writing what we
call feature pipelines and explain what
future pipeline is not an ETL pipeline
that you're familiar with they're
similar but they may be also written in
spark they might be written in pies bark
but they're different to the traditional
ETL pipelines that people may be
familiar with and the goal of this is
that we want to make the data scientists
life easier they can get ahead do their
modeling and change the world one click
through at a time so I'll just jump in
and show you an API because people
obviously want to show me the money show
me the code this is how an our
particular feature store we did the
world's first open source feature store
in hubs works and this is how data
scientists use it basically they'll go
to go to this thing called a feature
store and we show you later on in a
quick demo but you have a flat namespace
of features and big companies like uber
have over 10,000 features we have a bank
in Sweden they have about 400 features
and that will grow over time but the
data scientists will go first and
foremost through the features store to
see if the features are there to build
their models if they're not they will
need to bring in a data engineer or if
you're good enough you can do it
yourself and what the data engineer will
do is then register new features in the
feature story so what the data scientist
gets to do is pick the features they
want to train their models with and then
generate the training data set in the
file format that they're interested in
this is another issue that crops up when
you when you come to large enterprises
you get people who like Thai torch
people who like tensorflow
I want the training data
records I wanted an umpire raise you
even have more scalable formats like
pedestal for parallel data training so
with a feature store it's trivial to
create your training data and test data
in the format that you want so if you're
a data engineer and you want to actually
register a feature with this feature
store what you need to do well in our
particular feature store all you need is
a data frame by default it's a tiny
spark data frame but it can be upon this
data frame so you create a data frame
with your engineered features and then
you just register it with the feature
store and it can be available then for
data scientists to use it so that's the
quick overview now many of you will know
what a feature is I give this talk
sometimes the data engineers and I don't
think we've many of them here so they
think a data feature is often the column
in a in a data warehouse in a table and
data warehouse well we know that it's
not that typically features are computed
there may be aggregated doze if we're
trying to do predictions of time series
data or we're looking at transactions
and fraud and we often we use things
like graph embeddings to predict fraud
in anti money laundering
you know if you're working with raw
image data sound data you'll consider
pixels maybe features but we know that
these features basically can come in
many different formats and typically we
need to compute them it's not just data
you pull directly from your data
warehouse so the features store will not
be just structured data you find in a
typical data warehouse so some of the
problems we see what feature engineering
is that imagine there's a new cool
pre-trained model called burt that
appears and burt is the state of the art
for natural language processing now so a
lot of different maybe organizations
within a larger enterprise will decide
they want to play with Bert and they
have some raw text that they like to to
you to use birth to train some some
prediction problem with so what they'll
do is they'll take the raw data they'll
write some code to engineer the features
that Bert expects there's pre train
model and we'll have duplicated feature
engineering work here so the different
teams will write the same code twice and
maybe you know worse than one place
better another place but there'd be no
global enterprise level knowledge of
what features are available in the
organization the other main problem that
we see with
Engineering in when people thought
models into production is that you may
write different code for implementing
features see in this example so when
you're training it maybe you're
computing Windows and you know you're
computing your window and then when you
in your implementation so you have an
online service that needs these windows
it's computing it slightly differently
maybe you're computing the mean and one
in the median another feature and this
can cause obviously large problems in
prediction of your deployed model so
feature implementations may not
necessarily be consistent if you don't
have a structured way of accessing your
features so what we want to do is we
want to make these features available as
first-class entities in our platform
whatever your flat phone may be features
should be discoverable you should be
able to reuse them across different
models at your training they should be
access controlled version governed and
very importantly they should be
available to make your models
reproducible so you should be able to
say I would like to use this feature
this version when I use this feature in
this version to Train this model and
then you can use provenance to basically
take a model and say well which features
were use which versions and you can go
back and forwards that way you also use
the feature store as a way to reduce the
time it takes you to train models
because often when you're training
models you wait a long time to generate
your training data so the feature store
can back fill a lot of the feature data
so you can have a job which is filling
up the feature store every hour keeping
your windows up-to-date so you don't
have to recompute them when you want to
do your training and this important for
things that are computationally
expensive like aggregates embeddings but
for many people they still want to do
round amount computation of features
it's not always going to be precomputed
features so the just a quote from uber
who were the first people to write
publicly about their feature store
called Michelangelo they basically said
that the goal of the features store for
them was to solve the data problem this
80% of your time doing data munging so
that the data scientist won't have to
solve the problem themselves so I the
title of the talk was data engineering
meets data science and the way we look
at it as a feature star as an
abstraction you can think of it as an
API
an application programming interface
data engineers will spend a lot of the
time adding and removing features
they'll take the data from the different
data stores the raw data and they'll
make them available in the future store
and data scientists who maybe are Python
experts but not necessarily pi spark or
even Scala experts would like to just
use those features to train models and
how this feature store fits in in our
particular case how it fits into
pipelines because when you train a model
and you want to use that model in
production that pipeline is the basic
unit we have of deploying machine
learning models the pipeline is a way of
reproducibly taking data converting it
into models and making those models
available for applications to use so a
typical pipeline will go from raw power
structure data into features and the
feature will be used to train models and
those models will then be deployed and
validated and one thing that we also
notice is that when you're serving
models you may have to access features
so you know if you're doing for example
anti money laundering and you get a
transaction comes in we train our model
and 300 features those 300 features are
not available in the model in the
transaction data itself so we have to go
look them up we go to the feature store
we get the latest features and this
needs to be a low latency operation and
then we can then feed that feature
vector to the to the model to make the
prediction so there's two main use cases
you could say of the features store one
is the offline feature store so when
you're running batch applications or
streaming applications so these are
applications that work on large amounts
of data or big data you may think of
spark applications flink or spark
streaming applications as streaming
applications they're basically jobs that
will run so you can imagine for example
you have a very large data set of users
or customers and you want to do a
marketing jobs we want to go through all
the users score them and then we'll will
basically send some marketing material
or address different segments based on
the score so what you would do is you'd
register your features that you're going
to use to train this model with the
feature store then you can create your
training data from those features you
select those features you're going to
use to train your model save the model
it's available now if it's SK learn it's
a it's a pickled Python object or it's a
TV file protocol
as father for tensorflow and then at a
later stage you're you right streaming
out the streaming app is gonna use that
model to basically go through all of
your users and then make a prediction as
to what type of marketing activity I
want to make it this user based on the
underscore so in that case what you're
going to do is you're going to get the
job to compute those features based on
these new users that you're supplying
get your model in our case we're using
calendar environments I'll discuss that
later on and you could also add our
profile if it's a different type of
feature stores that would be the
environment that was used to to train
the model because you want to have the
same Python dependencies when you're
computing your features and then finally
you can run the job in this case it may
be just an embedded model that you used
for your predictions and then you print
out the results and or use them for
analytics since they're typically batch
or streaming application use of the
feature store the other use of the
feature stores if you if you have online
applications so your online applications
if we look at the top right hand corner
they're gonna have some some feature
data come in and they'll go to the
feature store and say please make a
prediction but you need to actually
enrich this data because I'm missing
some of the features so then you go to
the online features store to to add
those new features that are missing and
then you'll get a response back because
the model will have made a prediction or
based on the full feature vector that
you fed in so the way you work with the
online feature store is pretty similar
to the offline feature store you
engineer your features you register them
with Dolf online features store then
your your your data scientists will
create training data from those features
train models deploy them in this case
they're gonna deploy them in models
they're being served over the network so
in our case we serve models on docker
containers on kubernetes so SK learn or
tense form of serving server for
tensorflow
so there's a bunch of feature stores out
there and we can see our ones up at the
top but it's it's the world's first open
source feature store but they're other
ones that have been announced by
companies very large companies but they
haven't been made public the only one
that's has some source code available as
go-jacks feast system it's it's it's
tightly coupled to Google compute engine
so it's using BigTable and B
but you can see the source code the
other systems have been announced by
these companies are being be Comcast
Twitter uber but they haven't released
source code as of yet so a few words
about our future store and maybe I'll
get time for a quick dental so we have a
platform it's called hops works it's a
data platform for AI so you can think of
it as being a a platform where you can
store lots and lots of data do compute
jobs at scale
it supports batch analytics so you would
typically use spark to to do
computations at scale we've the data
warehouse hive we support streaming
analytics with flink or spark streaming
and then for machine learning the
platform that you can see the feature
store is a key part of it but we also do
model serving and distributed model
training as well and typically all
development is done in Jupiter notebooks
which is quite unique
so just to motivate this platform many
of you will have seen this slide it's it
talks about complexity in training
machine learning models in the real
world so in the real worlds that little
box in the middle is just a small part
of the problem of training models you
have to collect your day that you have
to validate your data if do your feature
engineering we hide that away with the
feature store so the purpose of our
platform is to make it easier to do deep
learning machine learning at scale and
large volumes of data so what we're
doing is encapsulating a lot of these
different components and systems that
you require to do machine learning at
scale behind the feature store but also
behind some api's that i'll discuss in a
second so some of the some of the things
that we do are things like distributed
training hyper parameter optimization
managing pipelines serving models and
monitoring models as they're being
served so I'll just give you one example
of this just to elucidate it so we do
support distributed deep learning and we
really do think that this is the time
has come for a distributed deep learning
and the reason why is because it's just
as easy to write code that will scale to
lots of GPUs as it is to write it for a
single GPU we are using condon vironment
s-- to make sure that the same Python
libraries that you install are available
on all of the containers in your system
and this is based around something
called PI spark so if you haven't heard
of PI spark all you need to know is that
pie spark has something called a driver
which launches lots of executors so up
to n you can have hundreds or even up to
a thousand executors so each of those
could have potentially their own GPU
what we need to have them to make
distributed deep learning work is you
need to have a distributed file system
because each of these executors will
store logs they'll store tensor board
logs and they'll they'll have hyper
parameters potentially and they need
aggregate the results they need to share
the same training data they need to
output their models they need to check
points that are available and most all
of them where they're distributed file
system you have a nightmare of going to
the local file systems of all your
containers and getting your data out of
them so we do have a stack based around
this that the platform doesn't just
support AMD we are also open source or
sorry in video we are open source with
AMD which of Rock'em this is gonna come
out in the next few weeks there was a
talk at spark summit about this if
you're interested and at the top level
how programmers write code is basically
the write in Python code but it's
tensorflow
my torch Karis inside a PI spark and
that isn't as scary as it sounds right
so this is the code this is gonna you
can do hyper parameter optimization on
potentially hundreds of GPUs with this
code here so if we break this code down
quickly we can see that the driver is
the main scope here and all its doing is
specifying hyper parameters we've
addictive hyper parameters and then we
call this experiment dot read search is
going to do grid search of the hyper
parameters and we have this train object
down here which is really the method up
at the top dev train so this is going to
call Train on all of the executors so if
I start this with ten executors it'll
start with ten each could have a GPU I
could start also with a hundred I could
start would just want the code remains
the same so each executor will execute
this piece of code now you may be
confused and say well what if I have a
data set in tensor flow and I passed
that in what data tends for will
automatically shard at for you so each
executor will get a shard of the
training day
to train on that so that's hyper from an
optimization training you might say is
harder it is a bit harder but the code
isn't that different again your driver
code is going to be just experiment dot
some method name and then the function
where we're encapsulating our I
distributed training code and then the
executors all run this particular
function or this method here or function
call train and so what this will
actually do because it's collectable
reduces it will build a ring amongst the
executors who will share their gradients
around the ring and it's doing
synchronous stochastic gradient descent
so getting back to the features door a
little bit sidetracked there and the
feature store is it basically consists
of three new abstractions in our case
one is the features themselves we have a
flat namespace of features but when we
compute the features we compute them in
groups so this is really related to what
how we have data frames so if you have a
data frame with lots of columns each
column is a feature and the future group
is effectively a data frame because
we're registering data frames with the
future store but then the interesting
part is then you can generate training
data from any of your feature groups so
you can pick a bunch of features from
different feature groups the system will
do some query planning and look for a
common key on which to generate the
feature vectors if there isn't one you
you can supply one but you will need a
common key so it might be for example
the custom identity is common across all
the feature groups there might be time
that using time as your key but there is
some intelligence in the system in terms
of query planning there so we do online
monitoring model serving as I said for
SK learn and scikit-learn basically your
requests come in you may need to go to
the feature store to build on those to
enrich those feature vectors you make
your predictions and then we log the
predictions and in fact when you're
running a system and production you do
need to log your predictions because you
want to monitor it you want amount of
the quality of your predictions so the
way we do that is that the predictions
get loud to kafka and then a streaming
app like spark streaming can analyze
those and typically what you want to do
later on is you want to store those
predictions because maybe later on
you'll find out the eye
come and if you find out the outcome you
can join it to the prediction and it
will help you both measure model
performance but also generate new
training data okay so do we I said we
have something on pipelines so here's a
pipeline this is our pipeline and it's
Python all the way you start from your
raw data which arrives in Kafka from
there you can use spark or flink blinked
dual support beam and tensorflow if
you're interested in tents will extended
which we're working on we haven't
released yet but typically we use spark
for the feature engineering and then
from there we go to the feature store
our future store is built on hive which
runs on top of our file system hops the
fast which is a faster version of HDFS
and then from there we saw that that we
can distribute the training of our
models and the experimentation our
models by putting our PI torch or
tensorflow klaris application inside
this pi spark function and from there we
serve our models and kubernetes and then
finally we we we log the predictions
from our models are being served into
Kafka from where they can be read by
applications and all of this is
orchestrated with airflow and if you're
not familiar with air flow air flow is
an orchestration to again program in
Python so the whole of this feature
pipeline or this machine learning
pipeline and to a machine or pipeline
are programmed typically in Python
except sometimes we change any Ringo's
done in Scala but you can do it in
Python and what's interesting about our
platform is we actually believe
notebooks at the future and we're not
the only ones Netflix err you're not
writing most of their code on notebooks
and running them in pipelines as well so
what we can do is we can take write our
code in joopa notebooks build a pipeline
and air flow and then test it and
incrementally fix your notebooks and
keep running the pipelines and testing
your pipelines so that we basically
believe that data scientists should be
writing production code not writing some
code and handing it over the fence to
some nice to be implement so this may be
and to end pipelines but more commonly
what you would do is you would have one
pipeline to fill up your feature store
and another one to do training and they
might run at different cycles so maybe
you're going to update your future data
hourly or daily
the training will be done periodically
when your other your models degrade or
you decide to do it periodically the
feature store can be used as part of a
you know if you have a cloud platform
and you just want the feature store and
not the whole of our ant-man
if you learning platform you can kind of
do that I'll skip over that and I'll
just show you a quick demo so that we
can see what this kind of looks like and
this seems to work okay great so this is
the platform here you can see there's
like twenty one twenty two GPUs
available you can have like hundreds if
you want I think I have a notebook so
from here you can start notebooks and
decide how many GPUs you want how much
memory and CPUs and so on and this is
the a notebook showing you the feature
store I'll try and make it a bit bigger
so people can see this particular
notebook is basically going to you've
seen this one before it's taking house
sale data and it's looking at houses
sold so we have the data about houses
that are for sale houses that were sold
and we're gonna introduce a new houses
for sale data set and try and predict
the price of them so there's a lot of
feature engineering going on here and
what's different is that once we've got
down to our data frames with our data
frames down here they're retaining some
feature engineering still we can
basically store them in the future store
and this is what you do here you
basically say save this data frame like
I said it can be a panda's data frame or
a PI spark data frame and then it will
compute statistics for you which is
quite nice so let's have a look at the
statistics it'll compute so this is not
the one here this one here so these are
projects by the way and feature stores
are per project so you can have many
features stores on the same platform so
this is the feature store our particular
feature store here you can see that we
have the flat namespace of feature names
here in the feature types I don't have
any descriptions of them and then the
groups of features and we have a job to
compute the features and then we can
look at statistics for features so this
is computed automatically once you
register it with the platform you get
your you can look at descriptive
statistics you know I mean my campus
standard deviation so basically data
scientists go here
the features look at the distributions
of the future values and try and
understand them before they go off and
build their models so at this point the
data engineer is finished and the data
scientists will take over the data
scientists will basically decide hey I
need to create a training data set I'm
gonna pick some of these features so
they'll go back here to our features
door they'll look through these features
search for them find ones that they
think are interesting and in this case
we've decided that the features that are
interesting our average house age
average house size RJ's worth average
number bidders on average sold for
features and what we do is we just
basically have this would be a whole
notebook create the Train data set and
create as TF records but you could
create as numpy object if you liked and
then from there you basically write your
normal tensorflow application if you
like tensorflow
one point of it tensorflow if you're not
familiar with it is that TF records is
very messy and right you typically have
to define the schema in your code but
when you have a feature store you can
just go to the feature store and say
well give me the schema for that TF
record and basically you don't need to
know write all that code into your
notebook anymore and then from there we
can basically define a model of training
function and launch it so that's
basically how the feature store
integrates into our platform the one
point I will mention a bit in platform
that makes it different to every other
platform is that we do have
kondeh environments for this particular
project here we have a replicated khand
environment at all the hosts so you can
basically pip install libraries here so
data scientists don't need to write
docker file so you can basically pip
install paper install pip install when
you're happy and everything's fine and
dandy you get a comp a Yama file
describe me your account environment and
that can be used in production and to
get your reproducible infrastructure ok
so that's that's the quick demo over and
let's go back so you can try this out so
it's like I said it's open source and
we're doing lots of new things for us
I'll show you in the next slide it's hot
site but we have we have a managed
platform at the Research Institute in
Sweden we call rice we can give you
access to it if you register there I'll
approve
there's 23 24 jeep use there that you
can use but it's also open source and
you can just install it on Amazon or
Google Cloud or on your own it runs on
premise as well if you've your own
cluster so some of the things we're
working on in terms of the future store
is things like data provenance where we
have some nice new features on being
able to track from a model to say which
features were used to train us and then
you can look at features and say which
ones are most popular used in models you
can also clean up training data sets
when they're no longer used by models
that have been trained and then we have
some other improvements in terms of how
we use hive as our backend so like I
said if you go to that site hop start
site and register this evening I'll
approve the account you can try this out
we're on Twitter the platform is called
hops works it is the your only European
Big Data Platform and we are currently
the only one at least I know on premise
who will allow you to do training up to
hundreds of GPUs on premise and that's
with that I think I'll take questions
if there's time yeah we've got two
minutes of questions it's got a question
please use the mic in front of you and
push the button I can repeat it sir I've
got one there yeah hi can you have a
stupid question can you have tax on the
features that you're generating so the
question is can you have tags on the
feature that you generated so the
feature store does have metadata for the
features so we have descriptions of them
and names for them and they're
effectively tied so you can search
through them
yeah I had a question about your data
formats
I saw you mentioned TF records if you
could go into that a little bit more in
detail and also if there's what's behind
it essentially in your back end if it's
stored in columnar data parquet or if
you're looking into sort of more
cross-platform data formats like a bunch
of air oh yeah so so patch ER is not a
file format so what I mean by file
format is the format of the data is
stored on disk to be used by the machine
learning framework of choice so if
you're using tensorflow the native file
format for ten suppose TF records and
it's not a columnar data format in the
sense that you can't say hey like so
I'll give you an example
uber generate huge amounts of training
data tens of terabytes and what they
have is hundreds of features so if they
have that in TF records they'd have to
read all of that up and then in memory
they drop the columns that they weren't
interested in that wasn't interesting to
them so they introduced a new format
that called pedis norm that we support
there as well
that's a calendar format TF records is
not really calendar in that sense you
can't select columns numpy is a native
format for pi torch and then you've hdf5
and CSV and a bunch of other ones
I mean basically it's to reduce the
impedance mismatch between reading and
the data converting it to the format
that the framework expects and using it
then natively
so the question is do we store many or
do we have one no you you decide you
take you pick the features and then you
decide this is the file format I would
like and then saves it in the
distributed file system yeah do you
offer this as a platform as a service
and what is a pricing model so if I want
to have a cluster of GPUs die install
the software my own cloud offering like
cs3 or yeah do you have that as backlog
of frequence part of your companies
later yeah sure and the price yeah but
it's open source as well but we do have
an Enterprise version or an enterprise
kind of thing yeah hey I was wondering
what led to the choice of my sequel for
the live features stores it's not my
sequence actually NDB you probably don't
know it it's a distributed in memory
database and it's the basis of our our
back-end file system so our file system
is the world's most scalable
hierarchical distributed file system
it's HDFS compliant we get like 1.6
million apps per second on Spotify
Hadoop work those and we do it with the
help of this distributed in memory
database we have papers at top USENIX
conferences you can read them up it's
call help service cool so we do it
because it basically maintains
consistent metadata across all the
services
[Applause]